c'est un parti dans une situation
paradoxale les républicains laminaient à
la présidentielle avec un score sous la
barre des 5% 4e groupe à l'Assemblée
nationale la droite républicaine joue
pourtant un rôle pivot notamment à
l'Assemblée nationale avec l'absence de
majorité absolue et LR font et défont
les majorités sur les bancs de
l'hémicycle et à ce titre peuvent
influencer le contenu des textes
législatifs c'est parti donc entre deux
eaux qui doit désigner un nouveau
président dans un mois les quatre et 11
décembre prochain les candidats ont
jusqu'à aujourd'hui pour déposer leurs
candidatures à sortie de 5000
parrainages au moins on en parle avec la
présidente par intérim du parti avec
nous dans le 13 14 aujourd'hui bonjour
Annie genvar bonjour Vos Questions chers
auditeurs au 01 45 24 7000 Annie genvar
qui est également député du Doubs
anisgène voir combien de candidats alors
qu'il est pour la présidence de votre
partie alors nous en avons nous en
avions 7 l'un a jeté l'éponge si je puis
dire il a renoncé à être candidat donc
il y en a 6 et selon toute probabilité
trois pourront réunir les conditions
c'est-à-dire avoir
485 parrainages d'adhérents et dit
parrainage de parlementaires le député
du Lot Aurélien Pradier le député des
Alpes-Maritimes le sénateur Bruno
Retailleau probablement Serge groart
maire d'Orléans alors Serge groart a
déclaré lui-même qu'il n'avait pas été
possible de réunir le parrainage des 10
parlementaires et selon toute
probabilité mais nous le saurons dans
l'après-midi pas de femme pas de femme
c'est dommage vous avez renoncé vous
alors j'ai renoncé oui oui c'est vrai
que il aurait été souhaitable qu'il y
ait une femme mais c'est ainsi cela
étant je pense que notre partie a des
progrès à faire en la matière vous
soutenez l'un ou l'autre candidat non
parce que en tant que présidente et
garante de la bonne marche de cette
élection je me dois une forme de
neutralité donc je ne soutiens personne
Annie genevois ils ont des positions
très divergent tout de même ces
candidats entre un Aurélien Pradier et
un Eric Ciotti est-ce qu'il y a vraiment
des choses en commun ah oui il y a
beaucoup de choses en commun il y a
d'abord cette ADN qui nous est commun et
qui nous est hérité du du goisme c'est à
la fois le l'importance attachée à la
nation
la défense de notre de l'attachement à
notre pays la France
l'ordre républicain
la solidarité bien comprise parce que
dans le gaullisme il y a aussi tout un
volet de solidarité
et l'attachement à la reconnaissance
elle a juste pris en compte des
territoires
l'importance accordée au travail comme
facteur d'émancipation donc dans l'ADN
de notre famille politique il y a tout
ça et je crois que vous ne trouverez pas
entre les candidats de différence de
fond sur ces questions là après ce sont
des différences qui peuvent s'exprimer
en terme de priorité ou de sensibilité
mais
ce qui nous rassemble et ce qui nous est
commun et
bien plus fort que l'expression
qui est inhérente à une élection quand
on est en compétition on cherche à se
différencier c'est normal mais en
réalité il y a ce socle commun qui est
très important et ils vont pouvoir les
exprimer ces différences et des journées
des rencontres thématiques fin novembre
alors effectivement nous aurons un
conseil national le Conseil national
c'est un peu le Parlement du parti et
les trois candidats si ce sont bien les
trois qui sont retenus comme c'est
probable et viendront s'exprimer devant
les conseillers nationaux et pourront
faire valoir leur projet pour le parti
alors il y a déjà des inquiétudes de la
part de ces candidats sur d'éventuels
fraudes ou manipulations on a entendu
moi je fais des vrais cartes des vraies
cartes d'adhérents on a entendu moi je
ne fais pas adhérer des chats et des
chiens alors c'est vrai qu'on se
souvient de l'époque de l'UMP avec
l'histoire de la de la coco des
difficultés pour départager les
candidats Fillon
développer comment vous éviter que ça se
reproduise ce genre de choses alors déjà
on a un prestataire qui est très très
professionnel il est d'ailleurs il
intervient d'ailleurs dans de dans de
nombreuses instances il est parfaitement
reconnu et c'est lui qui est le garant
de le bon fonctionnement de l'élection
on a une haute autorité qui veille par
le contrôle qui l'exerce à ce que les
choses se passent tout à fait
bien sur le plan de de
l'observance des règles et puis on a
fixé un modus enfin Modus opérandit qui
qui est très exigeant il faut pour voter
recevoir à son domicile un
identifiant une fois que l'opération ne
veut est engagée on reçoit un code sur
son portable ou sur son mail tout ça est
très contrôlé et puisque vous évoquez
des des choses un peu fantaisistes qui
se sont passées dans dans une récente
élection
je rappelle quand même que toutes ces
candidatures fantaisistes n'ont pas pu
effectuer jusqu'à son terme les
opérations de vote donc tout ça est très
contrôlé en réalité et parfaitement
parfaitement juste et le rebond du
nombre d'adhérents récents parce qu'on
est passé de 48 000 en juin à 77000
aujourd'hui ça ne vous inquiète pas ce
sont des vrais adhérents parce que Bruno
Retailleau demandait des garanties
notamment alors Bruno Retailleau
demandait des garanties je les lui ai
donné il s'en est d'ailleurs satisfait
il rencontreront notre prestataire la
semaine prochaine et puis
faire des cartes c'est aussi
démontrer sa capacité à convaincre
80000 adhérents sa place notre formation
politique en tête en termes de nombre
d'adhérents à tous ceux qui entèrent un
peu vite les républicains c'est une
belle preuve de vitalité on est quand
même loin de avant la présidence c'était
140000 un peu moins de 140 000 oui mais
enfin la présidentielle c'est un enjeu
qui est perçu quand même se mettant plus
conséquent que l'élection interne je
rappelle que c'est une élection interne
malgré tout Denis nous appelle de l'Oise
bonjour Denis
[Musique]
véritable
puisqu'on voit à l'ensemble qu'ils sont
plutôt les supplétifs du gouvernement
actuel bornes peut espérer un jour être
à nouveau un parti de gouvernement merci
pour votre question Denis la réponse de
la présidente du parti République
je récuse ce terme de supplétif pourquoi
est-ce que nous n'avons pas voté la
censure du gouvernement ça fait une
poignée de semaine que nous sommes élus
est-ce que les Français ont
véritablement envie dans ce contexte si
difficile pour eux d'une nouvelle
période électorale probablement qui
déboucherait sur une situation qui
serait pas plus clair qui ne dégagerait
pas forcément une majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée nationale je crois pas que
ce soit ce dont les Français ont envie
nous nous avons fait le choix non pas de
la provocation mais celui de la
responsabilité c'est-à-dire d'infléchir
la politique du gouvernement par les
propositions que nous faisons sur chacun
des textes qui qui sont plus utiles aux
Français que les vociférations
parce que faire tomber le gouvernement
il faut
nous excluons pas de déposer nous-mêmes
une motion de censure si naturellement
nous jugeons que ça soit que ça serait
utile aux Français mais pour l'heure sur
quel sujet ça pourrait se faire un
hygène va je ne sais pas si
véritablement la situation est
complètement été complètement bloqué que
nous jugeions que la situation sociale
politique économique soit suffisamment
grave qu'elle justifie une forme de
remise à plat démocratique que suppose
une élection peut-être le Furion nous en
tout cas on en exclut pas l'hypothèse
mais joindre nos voix à la nuque ou
rassemblement national dont je rappelle
quand juillet il n'avait pas voté à
mesure de censure donc il n'est pas
habilité à nous donner des leçons en la
matière nous ne sommes pas les
supplétives je veux vraiment m'inscrire
en faux de cette idée Denis parce que
nous avons fait évoluer les textes du
gouvernement sur énormément de sujets on
les a forcés à bouger et on veut les
forcer à réformer là où nous jugeons que
c'est absolument nécessaire et utile aux
Français donc ni supplétif ni on est
dans je dirais le rôle d'une opposition
responsable et crédible alors là où je
vous rejoindrai peut-être c'est que
évidemment c'est un peu moins lisible
que la protestation ou la vocifération
ou la provocation mais on peut pas jouer
sur les deux tableaux alors dans la
provocation et dans la crédibilité Annie
Genval on va prendre au cas par Cap par
exemple dans les échos
les échos ont l'air de croix savoir que
le gouvernement espère une alliance avec
LR à l'Assemblée sur le projet de loi de
finances rectificative qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à ça est-ce que c'est
effectivement une possibilité alors le
gouvernement peut toujours espérer il
n'est pas interdit d'espérer pour
entreprendre il y a pas eu de nom de non
négatif c'est juste non nous on a une
idée très précise de ce qu'on veut
trouver dans ce texte de ce projet de
loi de finance rectificative on veut des
mesures pour les propriétaires en
matière de lutte contre les passoires
thermiques on veut peut-être trouver
également une mesure carburant pour
alléger la facture des Français qui ont
besoin de prendre leur voiture pour
aller travailler
bref si on obtient pas des avancées
significatives sur ce texte de loi on ne
pourra pas le voter mais je vous
rappelle qu'il y a trois choix possibles
pour le contre et l'abstention donc
c'est vrai qu'on menait chèrement nos
positions sur chaque texte de loi hier
en commission
la commission des lois examinée la loi
locmin la loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'intérieur on a charmant négocié des
places en centre de rétention
administratif pour les personnes
qui sont sous le coup d'une obligation
de quitter le territoire français voilà
des exemples précis que je peux vous
donner à ce propos Annie Genval le prof
futur projet de loi immigration qui a
été tout récemment présenté
LR pour l'instant ne semble pas
enthousiaste à l'idée de voter ce projet
qu'est-ce qui vous faudrait pour
effectivement joindre vos voix à celle
de la majorité alors on n'est pas du
tout du tout enthousiaste sur ce projet
de loi parce que c'est une une
incroyable démonstration due en même
temps macroniste vous avez
Gérald Darmanin qui tente de parler à la
jambe droite de sa majorité en
augmentant les obligations de reconduite
à la frontière sans en donner d'ailleurs
démonstration les rendant plus efficaces
en les rendant plus efficaces mais vous
savez comment il les rend plus efficaces
en proposant et ça c'est la jambe gauche
défendue par Olivier du en proposant de
régulariser massivement des étrangers en
situation irréguliers alors forcément
je crois que on n'est pas du tout dans
la même logique que celle qui est portée
par le gouvernement une immigration
choisie c'est pas du tout ce que propose
le gouvernement le gouvernement propose
d'intensifier et la circulaire valse
donc une mesure de gauche qui consiste à
acter
l'irrégularité d'un certain nombre de
personnes et de les de les régulariser
c'est pas du tout la logique de
l'immigration choisie d'une immigration
de bon niveau et sur voilà sur décision
du Parlement là c'est pas du tout du
tout là
pour l'instant la porte est fermée parce
que il n'y a pas la démonstration de ce
que nous envisageons
en matière d'immigration pour nous la
question qui se pose c'est de pouvoir
favoriser l'intégration on voit bien que
notre pays est morcelé archipelisé que
l'immigration n'est absolument pas
contrôlée en disant on sera sur 4
millions
de d'étrangers supplémentaires alors
qu'on peine tellement à loger intégrer
alphabétisé donc c'est pas du tout la
voix qu'il faut prendre année Genevard
député du Doubs et présidente par
intérim du parti les républicains merci
nous avoir répondu sur France Inter
l'élection à la présidence DLR ce sera
les quatre et 11 décembre prochain